that all week the olympic podium being
used to protest
american shot putter raven saunders
being investigated after crossing her
arms above her head
during the medal ceremony this weekend
she says it's to represent oppressed
people and is telling the international
olympic committee
to try and take it her medal
this comes as olympic hammer thrower
gwen berry who turned her back on the
american flag during the national anthem
at the olympic trials
says she'll do it again if she reaches
the podium saying quote
i feel like i've earned the right to
wear this uniform i'll represent the
oppressed people
that's been my message for the last
three years all those people who hate me
they aren't here yeah so they can't
affect me
all right katie what do you think come
and take it
well we'll see if the investigation
plays out there are different rules from
the olympic committee and international
committee on what you're allowed to do
when you're protesting but i don't want
to focus on the people who are not proud
of the country they're representing i
think we should focus on
those who are making our country proud
like the men's relay team over the
weekend when they won gold and swimming
that was amazing
loved watching that and also to
emphasize the point that
our usa athletes can get up there and
they can protest and come back to a
country where
they have freedom and the freedom of
speech to speak out against things that
they think are unjust in the meantime
there's a belarus runner
uh her name is christiana her last name
starts with the t
i will not try to say it just try it
katie just try it
tis mon oskaya perfect
and she spoke out against belarus
officials uh and criticized them
and her life is now in danger and she's
trying not to go back to belarus because
she thinks that she will be either 12
killed but belarus oh
i'm such a jury anyway the point is
that if you're an american athlete you
can protest and come back to a country
and
live freely whereas if you're from a
number of other countries the majority
of them around the world you have no
rights to do so either at the olympics
or when you go home
or to belarus tomato tomato right now
i actually agree with agreeing with
y'all today i agree with katie on that
point it makes my life easy um
belarus but uh you know i think that is
what makes america great is that you can
go to the olympics you can win a gold
medal or a silver medal or a bronze
model for america and then you can
express your agreements with the country
that's what makes america a good place
and this is nothing new right we saw
this happen in the 1968 games when
um tommy smith and john carlos protested
the united states and mexico city
um we've seen it happen when muhammad
ali did the same thing
and listen this politics and politics
and athletics have always sort of been
connected even when richard nixon sent
the table tennis team to china
um so this is nothing new and i'm happy
to see that these players are expressing
themselves i honestly don't mind
this as much as the knee the knee really
drove me nuts but this
not the best but not the worst oh i
think there were some amazing things
including that guy um isaiah jewett who
was tripped
by the guy who's on our team usa tripped
by the guy behind her from botswana
ruins his race he was on track to win
and uh
instead of getting mad gets up shakes
his hand
and they run and that's not my reaction
nope that would not be yours
no but botswana tries that on me
but i think that's the lack of
sportsmanship here's the thing
first of all if gwen barry wants to
protest first you got to win okay so
then and then
and then let's talk yeah right like if
you win the match she might win the
medal okay fine but if she doesn't
she's like when you are this is the
thing about it
if you're going to do this you can't
just like say
preview it right it loses all of its
impact right so now we're all like
waiting like first of all we don't know
if you're going to win a medal
second like if you do it it's like oh
gosh here she goes like i already get it
but also know this
if you decide to do this and that's your
right if you you think that's your right
you have to understand that everyone has
a right to an opinion
about that action as well so then don't
get mad
if you get a reaction and you have a lot
of strong opinions yes in fact well
first of all i still go back to my
original solution we need to have an
activist
olympics combining activism with
physical fitness because let's be honest
about i i always worry
about the average activist they're often
terribly out of shape
overweight they look very unhappy
miserable if we can just get them into
some kind of routine of physical fitness
perhaps with something like it's not
like i would call it the activist
olympics
and and and just let them i think would
be beautiful
now your point is you know we have
athletes making political points
this is a political show i should be
able to make
comments about athletes i don't think a
lot of these people are very good
athletes
no was that before after they won the
gold or silver oh i just don't i just
don't consider a lot of these things
actually like hammer froze so that's my
opinion on some of these olympic sports
also
people like to watch the olympics
because they like to root for somebody
your team team america it's not just a
personal
athletic endeavor you're representing
your country
so this isn't like the nba or the nfl
where you can be
you can live in l.a and be a fan of the
of the knicks whatever
so it gets tiresome for a lot of people
when you want to support them but they
come
off as unthankful brats
and see now this is my opinion on the
athletes a lot of them
are uh ungrateful brats
uh you know are americans rooting
against the america
at the american female soccer team i
know a few who are
i don't know i mean and it's because you
don't
they come off as super smarmy and the
fact is the olympics are created for a
point of national pride being number one
you you every day you want to know how
many medals you have
that's what the metal county yes and
we're up two on china but the point is
i should say being woke that being
number one uh
jesse doesn't matter if you're if you
come from a racist country
that's the message being nobody's the
idea of winning doesn't matter the
number of medals doesn't matter that
that these athletes are unique specimens
that no longer matters either right
because they punctured
every one of these aspirational values
with their behavior
so that it doesn't really matter to me i
don't so i get to look at him and go
you're not really that good
you're boring i don't care about that i
used to care
i used to actually put forth this
compassion because you were part of an
america's team but now i don't give a
damn
and what's the difference between mexico
and the united states there's no borders
there
oh good point it doesn't even exist it
doesn't even exist anymore yes
they might just a little combined
mexican i mean it's worth pointing out
that raven sanders she did not
she saved her protest until after the
chinese anthem and after the medals were
handed out
and so she waited for the photo to
actually do that did anyone throw an x
up for their chinese
point now
jesse on saturday jamaica won one two
and three in the women's one hundred i
told you we're finished i love jamaica
i'm rooting for i'm martini
i'm a proud jamaican american and i root
for both countries
in jamaica jamaica total cat
one two three you guys aren't even in
double digits are you coming up
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else